Are you sure this is a good idea offering services like this when we aren't certified?
We need the money.
What other choice do we have?
Plus, I've never heard about needing to be certified to tangle someone.
Are you sure you're the mature one between us?
Very funny. Now shh, act professional.
Thank you so much for supporting us with your hard earned cash.
I appreciate it, but there is no time like the present, so please allow us to tangle you senseless.
Have we done this before?
Oh sure, we've actually had lots of clients.
Sorry if the flyers seemed a little desperate.
We just needed to pay for our nails and other girly stuff.
You can so tell we're desperate.
We already have an assortment of tools to test on you.
If at any point you'd like us to pause because you're just tingling all over from meant to toe, then just raise your hand.
If not, please close your eyes and enjoy this immersive experience with us.
One tingle after another.